So another weekend goes by and a more serious
questions about the stability of president
Trump.
Over the weekend.
Donald [inaudible],
Donald Trump used, uh, some horrible dog whistles
about mostly Black Baltimore being infested.
And of course people reacted to that.
And we'll discuss that separately.
And I, I'm thinking my take on it may be a
little different than much of what has been
around over the last couple of days.
But once again, in the big picture, Donald
Trump is reacting extraordinarily radically
to the growing reality that the congressional
push for impeachment has been reinvigorated.
A judge has now been asked to release grand
jury evidence from Robert Mueller's investigation
more than 100 Democrats in the house now support
and impeachment inquiry against Donald Trump,
which I am also going to talk about later.
And Donald Trump went on a nearly 24 hour
tweetstorm completely unhinged.
We've seen to our Twitter storms, we've seen
even like 10 or 12 hour ones, if I recall
correctly, but this was something new altogether.
Now, uh, can anybody take the phone away from
Donald Trump?
It doesn't seem like that's the case.
Can anybody talk sense into Donald Trump about
these tweets?
No.
I don't know that it's necessarily seen as
a problem because even though these tweets
that I'm about to show you, expose that we
have an unstable president, uh, our, our dozens
of tweets where social media has now become
the equivalent for Donald Trump of a guy ranting
in the subway while urinating under the stairs.
I am going to make the case that actually
these tweets serve a purpose for Donald Trump
aside from the content, which is to continue
setting the agenda and the narrative at the
exclusion of other topics.
And I'm going to get to that in a little bit.
So let's get to some of the tweets that Donald
Trump sent out.
This is just the sampling.
Donald Trump's starting with, uh, from the
bottom up in chronological order.
Congressman Elijah Cummings has been a brutal
bully shouting and screaming at the great
men and women of Border Patrol about conditions
at the southern border when actually his Baltimore
district is far worse and more dangerous.
His district is considered the worst in the
USA is proven.
Last week during a congressional tour.
The border is clean, efficient, and well run.
Just very crowded.
Cummings district is a disgusting rat and
rodent infested mess.
If he spent more time in Baltimore, maybe
he could help clean up this very dangerous
and filthy place.
Why is so much money sent to the Elijah Cummings
district when it is considered the worst run
and most dangerous anywhere in the United
States?
No human being would want to live there.
Where is all this money going?
How much is stolen?
Investigate this corrupt mess immediately
and then continuing consideration is being
given to declaring the Antifa, the gutless
radical left whack jobs who go around hitting
only non fighters.
People over the heads with baseball bats.
A major organization of terror along with
ms 13 and others would make it easier for
police to do their jobs going on.
The Democrats were trying mightily to revive
the badly and irrevocably tarnished witch
hunt hoax until Robert Mueller put on the
greatest display of an aptitude and incompetence
that the halls of Congress has ever seen.
Continuing.
The Dems are now coming out of shock from
the terrible molar performance and are starting
to spin impeachment all over again.
How sick and disgusting and bad for our country,
such a big victory for our country.
Supreme Court approves Trump administration
plan to use military funds for the wall.
Skipping over a few, you'll see that Donald
Trump continued this rant.
Sang, we gave an Adler and his Trump hating
dems, the complete Mueller report.
We didn't have to and even Mueller himself,
but now that both were a total bust.
They say it wasn't good enough.
Nothing will ever be good enough for them.
Which hunt?
No collusion, no obstruction.
Total exoneration, Democrat witch hunt.
Then he retweeted a bunch of Fox News videos
and continued tweeting about various quotes
regarding Robert Mueller's testimony.
Talking again about Congressman Elijah Cummings
who's been able to do so little for the people
of Baltimore.
Statistically, Baltimore ranks last in almost
every major category.
Cummins, as does Cummings, has done nothing,
nothing but milk Baltimore dry, but the public
is getting wise to the bad job that he's doing
and then going into conspiracies were real
collusion.
The conspiracy.
The crime was between the Clinton campaign,
the DNC fusion, gps, Christopher Steele, and
many others, including Komi McCabe, Lisa Page
and her lover or, and his wonderful.
And then he continues to go on with that,
um, getting into, uh, more conspiracies about
the Democrats are doing the Russians dirty
work and on and on and on, and truly stunning
fashion.
And then lastly, quoting random people from
Fox and friends, including you'll notice at
the top of your screen, Pete Hegg, Seth who
said Elijah Cummings has had his chance to
address it, crime and conditions in Baltimore
for decades and he hasn't gotten it done.
So endless, I mean endless.
A total of nearly 30 tweets.
This is the president of the United States
aside from the content of his tweets, which
is insane, aside from the amount of time that
he's spending tweeting the level of rage that
this man is exhibiting towards just everyone
is a sign that Donald Trump is very worried
if and when Donald Trump's finances really
start to be dug into by Democrats in the house.
And we're getting very close to that.
I believe that Donald Trump is going to go
the next to the next level.
This is a level which we still have not seen
and to be very clear, this is going to be
a level where all bets are off.
I mean, is Trump going to start actually calling
people the n word a?
I don't know.
He might.
He just Ma.
I don't know whether Trump has the restraint
not to do almost anything that we might imagine
if and when it gets to that point.
Now, there is another hypothesis that I was
reading about which might explain these extended
tweets, storms by Donald Trump.
It may be that the legal staff, either personal
lawyers or White House lawyers have started
to tell Trump, listen, there's a chance you
get indicted if you don't get reelected in
2020 I don't know how they'd couch it.
I Dunno what language they would use to explain
this to Donald Trump.
It's all still very speculative, but it is
not outside the realm of possibility that
Donald Trump is starting to be warned by his
own legal team internally about, listen, Mueller
is right by the letter of the law.
You can be indicted after leaving the White
House.
Winning in 2020 would be a sort of insurance
policy.
He likes to use that term, but it would be
an insurance policy for him against possible
indictment.
If you think Donald Trump is losing it now,
tweeting 30 times in 2018 hours or something
like that, just remember that between now
and 2020 there are any number of things that
could happen that will drastically escalate
Donald Trump beyond what we've already seen.
And for his sake, you'd think someone on his
staff would work to take away Twitter access,
but it's maybe easier said than done as we've
known, uh, as we've reported before and as
we've, we've known based on a number of different
reports, Trump will not even turn his phone
over for a security screening by intelligence
agencies.
So 2020 Trump is a Trump that will be running,
believing that it may take a win in 2020 to
keep him potentially out of prison.
Okay?
That is going to be a far crazier Trump than
we have ever seen.
And now I want to focus in a little more specifically
on the Baltimore tweets.